this is what it can sound like to be
caught up
in a gray zone style attack if shady
were an organization it would be
integrity initiative
documents reportedly leaked from the uk
funded influence network the integrity
initiative
debra haynes who is mentioned in
the integrity initiative files this is a
state-funded charity
that's been undermining british
democracy okay journalists are named in
them debra haynes a member of the uk
cluster just
uh part of the intelligence activity of
the uk
debra haynes foreign affairs editor of
sky news do you care about your
do you have no journalistic integrity at
all
foreign affairs evert editor for sky
these are comments from the
kremlin-funded news channel rt
a former labour mp and a youtuber for
the record
i'm not suggesting they were wittingly
part of any attack
it was late 2018 when reality briefly
disappeared
and i found myself under fire in the
gray zone
strangers online started accusing me of
working for the british government
against russia
over twitter they suggested i was some
kind of stooge
paid to make the kremlin look bad as
part of a shadowy operation
linked to the spy agency mi6
it was complete rubbish but i felt that
trying to respond to every allegation
would only feed the frenzy so i watched
powerless
as my reputation as an impartial
journalist was trashed
in a small but noisy corner of the
internet
i wasn't alone a number of other
journalists were also being
unfairly smeared it turned out we were
all collateral damage
from a suspected cyber hack against a
british organization
that ran a programme aimed at countering
suspected russian
fake news thousands of files
had been stolen from the institute for
statecraft a little-known educational
charity
that operates like a think tank they
were leaked online
and then picked up by rt and the russian
news site sputnik
to our top story of the new year more
revelations of a shadowy alleged
conspiracy involving
nato the uk foreign office and british
intelligence they appear to show the uk
government leading a massive operation
to control politics and public opinion
under sensational headlines it was
claimed the leaks exposed an anti-russia
influence campaign across europe run by
the british state
one of the documents listed several
journalists
including me prompting questions about
whether we were associated with the
scheme
there were also rather personal attacks
on twitter
this at hanes deborah is what a stooge
of the establishment looks like
masquerading as a journalist i wonder if
putin has these kind of puppets that
hashtag uk
establishment enjoys always bending the
truth away from people
hashtag integrity initiative propaganda
the perpetrators behind the attack have
yet to be identified
but a powerful way for one state to
attack another in the gray zone
is by stealing sensitive files through a
cyber hack
and then leaking them anonymously online
to influence public opinion
or to damage reputations the suspected
hack
of the institute for statecraft was
hugely damaging for the organization
but just imagine if the integrity
initiative
had successfully been raising awareness
amongst european governments and the
public
about the danger of suspected russian
disinformation
what better way to disrupt its
activities than for
russia to hack into its computer systems
steal documents and then leak them
into the grey zone
my name is debra haynes i'm the foreign
affairs editor at sky news
and you're listening to my podcast into
the gray zone
which explores a murky evolution of
warfare
i'll explain the covert tactics used by
states
criminals and terrorist groups to
deceive
gain influence and at times kill
in this episode i explore the gray zone
weapon
of hack and leak and how it's used by
states
to damage reputations and influence
mines
there's a huge amount of innovation in
this space by
by states and adversaries and criminals
paul chichester
is a veteran of the cyber gray zone he's
the director of operations at the
national cyber security center
which is part of the uk spy agency gchq
paul's talking about the act of stealing
and leaking data
weaponization of information to kind of
taking things and then saying well
how do i use this in the most disruptive
or kind of coercive way
it's been a form of attack for as long
as there's been pen and paper
in soviet times leaks of embarrassing
divisive or deliberately distorted
information
were a key part of a covert form of
political warfare
known as active measures thomas ridd
a professor from the previous episode
who wrote a book on the history of
active measures
talked to me about the evolution of hack
and leak
when intelligence agencies surfaced
stolen information in the 1970s they
often
you know mailed photographs of documents
or printouts of documents
with a cover letter to journalists
anonymously in order to write their
appetite and get them to cover the story
but today in the internet age you can
just put a lot of documents an entire
dump
online on some website or give it to
wikileaks
wikileaks is the online platform founded
by julian assange
that publishes anonymous leaks and what
happens next is that
the value creation here is to an extent
outsourced to the victim because instead
of
an intelligence officer or an
intelligence unit you know crafting a
cover letter or
for tree what happens is that people go
into the
dump journalists and others researchers
and pull out the gems pull out the
interesting tidbits
and in a way that maybe an intelligence
officer would have missed
and then they turned that into the
effective part of
the operation the internet and computers
also mean there's a lot more
information out there to be taken and
you no longer need to physically swipe
the files in person
instead if you're handy with a keyboard
it can be done anonymously
from anywhere on the planet
back to paul chichester probably the key
pivot point was
the u.s elections in 2016 when i think
people
started to realize that as a threat so
you know effectively taking you know
that that information you get through
hacking but then
taking it and then saying well how can i
leak this at the most important time or
the most disruptive time
to cause the most impact and and sort of
doing in doing it in a way that yeah say
has that that most disruptive effect
he's referring to a hack and leak
against hillary clinton's campaign
in the 2016 u.s presidential race which
she lost to donald trump
that operation was blamed on russia's
military intelligence agency the gru
that's the same agency the uk believes
was behind the salisbury spy poisonings
ben nemo the online investigator we met
in the previous episode
explains what happened russian military
intelligence
known as the gru hacked into
the service of the democratic national
committee in about
april 2016 and they hacked into the
emails of clinton's campaign manager
john podesta
and shortly before the democratic
national convention in july 2016 which
was meant to crown hillary clinton as
the official democratic candidate
the giu used a an online persona called
goose for two by naught and
uh a facebook page called dc leaks
to start leaking emails from the dnc and
and from other
high-profile americans that they hacked
guccifer 2.0
and dc leaks were two fictitious online
personas
that are believed to have been russian
fronts russia
has always denied involvement and and
this created a major scandal because it
came out that various
members of the democratic national
committee had been heavily
favoring clinton and had been very
reluctant to see bernie sanders who was
the main challenger
be nominated and there was sufficient
bias in there that just before the
democratic national convention the head
of the democratic national committee
had to step down because of this scandal
so if you think in terms of an
information operation there you've just
decapitated the political campaign
four months out from the election that's
a major victory for the information
operation because if the leaks hadn't
happened
that would not have come out the
following year
france also fell victim to a suspected
gru hacken leak
during its presidential election the
target
was then candidate emmanuel macron with
more than 20 000 emails linked to his
campaign
dumped online just ahead of a 44-hour
grace period
of election silence which restricts
reporting by french media
on election issues until after the polls
close
so the timing is is really key hall
chichester again
we're seeing more and more of that where
states and criminals looking at
ultimately you know
it's quite criminal um in terms of
uh approach and that you know when a
criminal steals information they will
look at how they monetize it the most
so originally that was well i've got
your um identity
i can sell your identity and then it
would be well that's that's quite hard
work
so what else can i get from that
information through to well actually now
i can just
you know extort you um states are kind
of going through that same analysis and
saying well i've got this information
and
it's quite interesting and it might tell
me what you're thinking but actually if
i leaked that
you know how can i have a sort of uh an
impact
in that it's not only politicians who
can be in the firing line
you may remember a 2014 cyber attack on
sony
that the fbi blamed on north korean
hackers
hello who is this is the secretary of
communication for north korea
our supreme leader kim jong-un is
interested in doing an interview with
dave skylark oh my god
we will meet 50 kilometers west of
dangdong northeastern china did you just
say china
and did you just say dong pyongyang had
been outraged
at a sony pictures comedy called the
interview it was about
two journalists played by seth rogen and
james franco
who traveled to north korea to interview
its leader kim jong-un
but are recruited by the cia to
assassinate him
a north korean foreign ministry
spokesman called the movie
the most blatant act of terrorism and
war and threatened what he described
as a merciless countermeasure then
just ahead of the release date hackers
penetrated sony's computer systems
stealing thousands of files and then
leaking them online
they included private emails from senior
executives
detailing unflattering observations
about various actors
it triggered a media frenzy and derailed
the movie launch
in the uk four years later a
little-known british organization
called the institute for statecraft also
fell foul
of this kind of greyzone weapon
right now the safest way to bank is from
home
at lloyd's bank there's so much you can
do to manage your money online
from viewing statements to managing
direct debits to paying bills
you can speak to a mortgage advisor by
video or over the phone
and even pay in checks using our app if
you do need to visit most branches are
open 9 30 till 2 monday to friday
please wear a face covering and observe
social distancing to protect yourself
and our colleagues
lloyd's bank by your side terms and
conditions apply
the current problem is that in
democratic countries most people are not
aware that there's a war on that's chris
donnelly
he's the man who set up the institute
for statecraft more than a decade ago
when he retired from the ministry of
defense
a fluent russian speaker chris who's 73
is an expert on russian warfare from the
conventional deployment of tanks and
troops
to the far more deniable use of politics
money
energy cyber and disinformation to
undermine an opponent
he suffered a stroke in 2018 that means
his speech is slightly slurred
most people are not aware of the change
in the nature or in the character of
conflict that's being waged
and they're oblivious to it and how
then we can get people to understand
this as far as we can see in the 21st
century is going to be how
wars and competition wage between
countries
and we have to find a way of working
these wars without
jeopardizing the values for which
liberal democracy stands
i was introduced to chris in early 2014
just after russia's annexation of crimea
and during the unfolding conflict in
eastern ukraine
back then most western governments saw
islamist terrorism
as their biggest security challenge and
had taken their eye off the ball
when it came to more traditional threats
posed by states
but that changed when russia backed
forces
unleashed a new kind of warfare in
crimea and ukraine
using a combination of disinformation
cyber attacks
and hard military power
suddenly chris's knowledge and expertise
were in high demand
because in one sense the nature of
conflict doesn't change it's nasty it's
vicious and all such things as
soft power weapons and nothing soft
about information or
economic weapons being used against the
country
he says the way to understand this
change in the character of conflict
is not to think about a battle between
two sides
but instead to see the world as a
darwinian ecosystem
in which instead of the animals of the
galapagos islands what you've actually
got
are nation states subset actors big
corporations
even charismatic individuals movements
cultural
forces these are the creatures of the
darwinian system
and the principle are firstly all of
these creatures are now competing with
one another
this is a war of all against all and
they're all competing against the
environment
and in that competition they all develop
different
characteristics different weapons to use
in the same way as charles darwin
observed how creatures
evolved claws beaks and stings to win in
a fight
so too did the players in today's
conflicts use everything as a weapon
from information and cyber attacks to
bribes and intimidation
ultimately it's survival of the fittest
and then remember what darwin also said
that the bigger players in his
universe would try and shape the
environment in their favor which is what
big actors do
but at the end of the day when you were
faced with rapid change
it wasn't the biggest and the strongest
which survived it was those most able to
adapt
but if we're going to survive in this
current period of rapid change
globalization when the rate of world
change is overtaking the capacity of
institutions to adapt
then if we can't adapt we'll fail
we'll lose that battle and in
institutions
countries organizations which can adapt
and which might well have
values and be run in ways we really
don't like
are going to succeed this is an
existential challenge it's a strategic
threat
we face and yet on the street outside
there's no sense of crisis there's no
sense of threat i don't think this is a
crisis it's nothing so
trivial but there's no sense of peril
no the biggest threat is that people
don't realize there's a threat
chris was one person who did realize
he set up the institute for statecraft
with a business partner
they registered it as an educational
charity in scotland
that found office space close to the
temple tube station in central london
alongside the river thames the institute
had a small team of staff
including people like chris with long
ties to the military and government
as well as younger analysts and
assistants it offered briefings and
papers
on issues of unsurprisingly statecraft
such as how to help governments think
strategically
about big issues like the rise of china
chris had a particular interest in what
he saw as the threat posed to western
democracies
by disinformation and other forms of
russian active measures
he helped set up a program called the
integrity initiative
it comprised a network of journalists
academics think tanks and other experts
from across europe
who all understood russia and had been
independently tracking
alleged russian attempts to meddle in
their respective countries
but those individuals had operated more
or less in a vacuum
talking to one another certainly in
english but not really having an impact
in their own countries so our aim was to
encourage them to develop in their own
countries clusters of experts who could
do this work
and who could inform their own
politicians their own academia
their own journalists i spoke to one man
who's part of a group of volunteers in
lithuania that tackle pro-russian
disinformation
spread over social media in the country
they're part of an international
online community that describes
themselves as elves
fighting what they see as the evil
internet trolls
now we're calling ourselves elves nobody
remembers who said first
that we are elves but i think the logic
behind it was pretty simple to also ugly
and bad
and also bright and shiny as an elf
he uses the name hawk when battling
trolls online
to protect his identity he knows chris
and supported the integrity initiative
did you feel like you were able
to have a greater effect because you
were part of a bigger network
of course that that's you know this is
this is
integration of the different levels
fighting finding disinformation and
where we can share our information our
insight
our research is between different
countries between different levels like
academic level
uh stratcom level and the volunteers
level i think it's it's great
interaction
and could you did you do was that is
that all thanks to chris and his
initiative
absolutely chris donnelly is extremely
intelligent
extremely smart and he's really a real
fighter
as he said we are the warrior and then
we are warriors fighting evil
awareness about suspected kremlin
interference
and how to counter it was already high
in eastern european states like
lithuania
that share borders and histories with
russia but chris wanted to reawaken
western europe too
to what he alleges our covert russian
efforts
to try and weaken alliances like nato or
the european union
his integrity initiative offered
seminars shared briefing papers
and organized for experts to meet with
officials in different countries
to raise awareness about the alleged
threat
posed to them by russian disinformation
and other tactics
it was very small scale at the beginning
but in 2017
the uk's foreign office started funding
the integrity initiatives overseas
activities
this funding increased the following
year as part of britain's response to
the salisbury spy poisonings
chris's tiny non-for-profit organization
suddenly became a serious player and far
more exposed
to the threat of a hostile information
operation
aimed in its direction
anyone seeking to undermine the work of
the integrity initiative
could use the genuine fact that it's
receiving government money
to add credibility to false claims that
chris
and his team were part of a shadowy
anti-russia campaign
run by the british state
which is pretty much what then allegedly
happened
and at that point of course it suddenly
became a target
keir giles the russia expert who we met
in the previous episode
knows chris and has worked with him on
other projects
though not the integrity initiative the
timing was unfortunate the funding that
came in
should have enabled integrity initiative
to set itself up on a professional
footing
including all of the defensive measures
that it should have been in place
because it was now
very much in the big league of taking on
nation state adversaries as opposed to a
a small cottage industry of maintaining
subject matter expertise as had been the
point up until then
unfortunately they were attacked before
any of those measures were put in place
we first realized there was a problem in
november 2018
when material that which had been hacked
from our servers
started to be published the hackers
uploaded integrity initiative documents
onto a website called cyberguerrilla
along with a message
purporting to be from the global
activist hacking group anonymous
there was no evidence it had anything to
do with them
they claimed the leaks showed britain
was running a large-scale
information secret service across europe
the us
and canada under the guise of combating
russian propaganda
the leaks had limited impact at first
until they were reported on by the
kremlin-funded tv channel
rt and the news site sputnik a video
also appeared online
greetings we are the anonymous charity
also known as the collective
we have obtained a large number of
documents relating to the activities of
the integrity initiative
project the attackers dumped stolen
files online in seven waves
they comprised about 2 000 documents in
total
including the names addresses and on
occasion
even bank details of hundreds of
individuals
while many of the leaked files were
genuine chris says some were tampered
with
for example there was a list
put out of individuals in armenia
with a description of who they were and
the list was in effect in
exposing these individuals as being
agents of the russian state in armenia
following a russian agenda
that resulted in quite a few of those
individuals making a complaint to the
british embassy but that list has
nothing to do with us
what's the intention why do they do that
well the whole
the whole aim is to create disturbance
to discredit
us in this instance and simply to cause
a problem to cause turmoil to cause
upset to muddy the waters everywhere so
you no one knows what's true and what's
false
the leaking online of the names of
individuals working with the integrity
initiative
had real world security implications
some of the people received physical
threats
one person i spoke to who lives in the
uk believes his home might have been
broken into
and objects moved around in a form of
intimidation
as it was dealing with the leaks the
institute for statecraft
also created a political embarrassment
for the foreign office in london
after a scottish newspaper revealed that
its integrity initiative twitter account
had retweeted a number of unflattering
articles
about the labour party and its then
leader jeremy corbyn
it included one that claimed his quote
visceral anti-westernism
helped the kremlin cause chris
acknowledges this was a mistake
and the institute apologized but labour
went on the attack
led by then shadow foreign secretary
emily thornbury
and there is i'm afraid absolutely no
doubt that the publicly funded integrity
initiative
has broken that rule on a repeated basis
by using its twitter accounts
to disseminate articles in attacking the
integrity
of conservative and labor officials of
conservative peers
and on a repeated basis the leader of
her majesty's opposition
and finally mr speaker if the government
intends
to renew that funding for the next
financial year
what arrangements and agreements will be
take will be put in place
to ensure that nothing
nothing of this sort ever happens again
in fact after all the controversy the
foreign office funding
wasn't renewed a spokesman for emily
thornbury said she'd made no criticism
about the objectives of the integrity
initiative encountering russian
disinformation
however he didn't reply when asked over
email
if she'd ever considered the provenance
and purpose of the leaks
which drew attention to the programme in
the first place
he just said ms thornbury was responding
to questions
about the integrity initiative's twitter
activity from the mainstream media
the fallout from the leaks didn't just
impact those directly connected to the
program
some of the hacked files contained lists
of people with no association to the
integrity initiative at all
but who became unfairly linked because
their names were leaked
they included diplomats military
personnel
and yes journalists
my name appeared on a list of
individuals reported to be part of a
uk cluster even though i wasn't part of
any such thing
in fact when i asked chris about it he
claimed
such a cluster in the uk never existed
his institute
had my name and contact details because
of who i am
a journalist who at the time was
covering the defense beat for the times
newspaper
i'd sometimes speak to chris if i was
researching a story he might have a view
on
i'd also visited his offices in 2016 to
meet a group of ukrainian military
personnel who traveled to the uk to give
briefings
on how they thought russian forces were
operating in eastern ukraine
speaking to informed people to find out
their view on a subject
is what journalists do but a reporter
for the russia-funded news website
sputnik
who spent months covering the leaks
falsely described me
in one of his articles as the integrity
initiative's favorite propagandist
being caught up in a very minor way in
the hack and leak
wasn't very nice but it's one of the
hazards journalists face
given that we deal with information
every day and information
can be and is used as a weapon in the
gray zone
for the institute though the attack was
devastating
the effect on the institute was
basically to make it very difficult to
continue to run the program
and to get the program funded for a
second year
and so that obviously had a financial
impact on the institute because it's
a small institute dependent on programme
funding for its effect
it was a personal it must have been like
an effect like emotionally on
on you and on everybody there was a
really serious emotional effect on a lot
of the staff
at the institute particularly those
working on the integrity initiative
program
firstly because they themselves found
themselves
attacked in disinformation attacks
secondly they were they were upset that
people they've been working with
in europe were being exposed in a way
which was was damaging
so actually it damaged the trust on
which the network was set up
but the main impact was effectively the
loss of funding
right now the safest way to bank is from
home
at lloyd's bank there's so much you can
do to manage your money online
from viewing statements to managing
direct debits to paying bills
you can speak to a mortgage advisor by
video or over the phone
and even pay in checks using our app if
you do need to visit most branches are
open 9 30 till 2 monday to friday
please wear a face covering and observe
social distancing to protect yourself
and our colleagues
lloyd's bank by your side terms and
conditions apply
the big remaining question is who
attacked the institute for statecraft
whitehall officials i spoke to in 2019
said they believed the likely culprit
to be russia's military intelligence
agency the gru
it might even have been in response to
the uk government
blaming the gru for the salisbury spy
poisoning
and vowing to shine a light on its
activities none of that's confirmed
though
and the allegation has been
categorically denied by russia
chris donnelly doesn't want to be drawn
on this question when i speak to him in
february 2020 for this podcast
who carried out the attack as far as you
can tell
we must assume it's a hostile state
actor
and why do you think it was a state act
not just some
uh disgruntled activist hacker
firstly there is the technical skill
required to break into the system but
but more important than that
is the the focus and the
persistence of the attack which cannot
be explained other than being a major
state actor that simply didn't like what
we were doing
gchq's national cyber security center
launched an investigation into the
suspected hack and leak when it first
emerged
its experts examined the institute's
computers and laptops
the ncsc is also helping to investigate
a russia-linked attack we covered in the
previous episode
of a stash of uk u.s trade documents
that were leaked online ahead of the
2019 uk election
paul chichester from the center can't
talk specifically about either case
because investigations are still going
on but he does give a sense of the kind
of work
the ncsc does in a suspected hack and
leak
what you're trying to do is again sort
of
actually from an ncrc point of view
trying to prove is there a
um a hack element so yes something's
been put online but actually where did
it come from
and actually can you now follow the
bread crumbs back and sort of say well
can i actually find where this
information came from
from our point of view in all of those
kind of scenarios certainly around
the election it's well we need to
understand that quickly so that we can
you know make sure that that if there is
an issue there we can we can close it
off we can work with the organization
and so that's very often our role is
trying to understand what's the hack
part of this i mean if it's leaked it's
leaked and that that's gone
but actually very quickly trying to get
back and say well we now need to
understand what
the wider impact assessment might be can
we find out where that data's come from
can we help
fix if there was a if there was a
vulnerability can we help fix that
that's kind of our focus
i ask him how easy or hard it is to tell
whether something's been hacked
so i think i mean again sort of we can
come at this from a number of ways so we
can
we can very much sort of from the work
we do in terms of understanding what the
adversaries are doing
we can try and um what we would say go
upstream
so try and see what they're doing and
see
what can we see them doing
reconnaissance on an organization have
you know what
what can we go back and look at that
might help us
suggest that yes they were behind that
there's also a lot of work we do with
the victim
and so either ourselves or with industry
we can go in
and effectively um do a hunt
for adversaries on the network and
obviously the adversary puts a huge
amount of effort into
making that job really hard and we put a
huge amount of effort into making
that job as effective as we as we can do
um
and we you generally we do it quite
effectively so
ultimately you'll you're really in a
kind of classic scene of crime space
there you're trying to put all the
different forensic bits of
information together um very often the
organizations don't have all of that
data
so you're taking you know maybe some
partial data that they had from
a sort of a log somewhere you might be
doing forensics on a
machine you might do a whole different
range of things and then trying to piece
together you know what actually happened
he explains how he and his colleagues
hunt for clues on a computer
so effectively if machines powered off
all the data is still on that that
device so basically imaging that device
taking a copy of it and then
going through it with um specialized
tooling
to look for malicious behavior and
telltale signs of that kind of malicious
behavior
very often adversaries are kind of wise
to that now so they do what they call
kind of in memory malware all
sort of capabilities which means the the
malware doesn't persist
so an adversary will attack that machine
and they will put something malicious on
there but only while the machine's on
so there's nothing on the disk so as
soon as you turn the machine off it's
gone
and you know we could spend weeks
looking at the the disk and
you wouldn't find anything so
increasingly doing it what we call in
memory forensics and actually going onto
the machine while it's on
and looking in the memory the running
kind of
machine and very often now so it used to
be very often you know the first thing
that you say to people with with uh some
sort of malware would be turn it off and
disconnect from the internet
um and very often don't turn it off
because that's you know the adversary
wants you to turn up as soon as you turn
it off
you'll never find what they did by early
2019
the national crime agency have become
involved in the investigation
that's significant because it typically
only deals with the most serious crimes
and has the power to investigate cases
with an overseas dimension
in march of that year i decided to do a
television and online report for sky
news
on the whole suspected hack and leak but
this triggered more false claims about
me being an integrity initiative stooge
including from this youtuber who
describes himself as a journalist and
podcaster
hi everyone i've got a bit of an update
on the integrity initiative
sky have written an article on it i know
i was shocked as well but look who is
written by
it's written by debra haynes who is
mentioned in the files in the integrity
initiative files
as being a member of the uk cluster
come on this is laughable
i mean seriously this is laughable
don't you care about your do you have no
journalistic integrity at all foreign
affairs
ever editor for sky then on the 25th of
march
the suspected hack and leakers uploaded
their seventh and final tranche of files
with this message greetings we are
anonymous
having found that sir alan duncan and
frau deborah haynes intend to keep on
misleading the international community
lie to members of the uk parliament and
feed falsehood to the media
we have again decided to break silence
to protect the informational environment
in civilized countries
sir allen was then a foreign office
minister who i'd interviewed for the
television
report despite suspicions about a
possible russian attack
the uk government hasn't made any public
statement
about who it thinks could be responsible
for what happened to the integrity
initiative program for chris
he's still waiting to find out exactly
who attacked his institute and how
and he's still counting the cost it's
quite an effective tool isn't it
so yes unfortunately it has been an
effective weapon
particularly because firstly as a small
institute we ourselves
didn't have the resources or the
expertise to fight it effectively
because and so how would you afford it
what would be an effective way to fight
it well if we had been stronger
organized or if indeed we had been
the front for the deep state which the
conspiracy theory
uses of being we would have had the
resources to launch
some form of counter disinformation
program
to counter the materials put out how
what's that how do you do a counter
disinformation program
you go around ex you go around
forensically
dissecting all the materials that's gone
online
and pointing out where the lies and
falsifications have taken
place and the misinterpretations and
getting your story out we simply didn't
have the strength to do that because
we are who we are as well as losing
their foreign office contract
the institute also had to respond to a
complaint made to the scottish charity
commission
about their work the commission launched
an investigation
which resulted in criticism of the
charity including over its integrity
initiative
but no formal sanction the institute has
now cut all ties with its
counter-russian disinformation program
so the impact's been pretty significant
on the
the work that your organization was
doing yes
but the other side of that coin is we
have dealt with it and we
have effectively restructured the
institute and
and even if we can no longer do this
kind of work we can still continue all
the other
good work which we have been doing for
some years but doesn't it make
isn't it isn't it just victory for them
though for
your attackers that you have been
squashed and silenced
in this instance i think they have won a
battle but they haven't won the war
one final thought if you consider hack
and leak as a weapon
in a war of influence then like it or
not
news organizations and social media
platforms are all part of the weapon
system
it creates a serious ethical question
about journalism and leaks
on the few occasions i've received
leaked information in my career
i've always known the provenance of that
information and the motivation of the
source
which has typically been a desire to
expose a problem or a wrong
in the public interest a core job of a
free and open press
is to hold those in power to account and
often that does require
leaks of information to reveal hard
evidence of corruption
or failure but what if one day i receive
an anonymous email
with an attachment of leaked files from
an unknown source
revealing evidence of a scandal
involving the government
yet i don't know who leaked this
information or why
for sure there'd be a strong public
interest to expose wrongdoing
and of course the sender could be a
genuinely concerned whistleblower
but what if this information had been
hacked by a hostile foreign state
and deliberately leaked to create
disorder in the uk
possibly even to topple a prime minister
i might simply be facilitating the
attack
here giles again journalists are in the
front line
because they have competing incentives
they are presented with something which
makes a sexy story because
it's stolen or hacked or leaked and yes
of course the material is going to be
enticing
but at the same time they don't know its
provenance they don't know whether it is
reliable
they don't know whether it was acquired
for a criminal act or if in fact it was
intended
to damage the country they live in put
all of this together and you have a
toxic
mix where there are conflicting
priorities for different people
to handle this material in different
ways but all of it
serves the attackers all of it is just
an enticement for people to spread this
information
far and wide and to pick over it for any
of the juicy details that will actually
embarrass
the people it was leaked from i asked
paul chichester
what he thinks a journalist should do if
given material
that might have been part of a hack and
leak operation by a hostile foreign
state
i'm hugely cautious about sort of
saying what journalists should or
shouldn't do i think at the end of the
day
if something's believed to be true then
you should report it there is definitely
something though
uh increasingly around how journalists
are both targeted by states
because they're reporting on certain
stories and how they can be used
again as you describe and i think
there's a there's there's more that we
can do i think to sort of
share what we see states doing and at
least help journalists understand the
threat that's out there so that they can
make their own judgment
it's definitely a hostile environment
and it can become a lot more hostile
when states choose to use cyber to cause
widespread harm
[Music]
looking for a cyber pearl harbor as
people call it
one massive event to change the course
of history
may actually be missing the point that
there's already so many
uh smaller events happening that really
should be stopped
but that's next time as we continue
into the gray zone
[Music]
into the gray zone is a sky news podcast
it was edited and produced by chris
scott and narrated by me
debra haynes additional voice provided
by matt steele
the head of sky news radio is dave
terrace
in this episode we've used youtube posts
from former labour mp chris williamson
and independent journalist and podcaster
gordon dimick
listen and subscribe wherever you get
your podcasts